Well, I thought my car had been stolen, which I was like, does that even happen? I guess it does, but, you know, my car is really old. It's like 2011 Mazda 6, so I really didn't know why anyone would want to take that car. This is Kelly Prime. We work together at 99PI and she lives in Brooklyn. And not too long ago, she had an experience that shook her. She and her friends had been out for the day in Coney Island. and they were stopping to get some takeout on the way home. They were looking for a place to park, not too far from the restaurant. And, you know, this is Brooklyn, so there's not a lot of parking available, and all the street parking looked like it was filled up. But on the right-hand side, we come upon this brightly lit, beautiful, empty parking lot in front of a 7-Eleven. Perfect, like irresistible, it sounds like.
嗯，我还以为我的车被偷了，当时我就想，这种事真的会发生吗？我想会的吧，但你知道，我的车真的很旧。那是2011年的马自达6，所以我是真不知道会有人想要偷那辆车。这是凯莉·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）。我们在99PI一起工作，她住在布鲁克林。不久前，她经历了一件让她心有余悸的事。她和朋友们那天去了康尼岛（Coney Island）玩。他们打算在回家的路上顺便买点外卖。他们在离餐厅不太远的地方找地方停车。而且，你知道的，这里是布鲁克林，所以没有多少空余的停车位，而且所有街边车位看起来都停满了。但在右手边，我们遇到了一家7-Eleven前面灯火通明、非常漂亮、空无一人的停车场。完美，听起来就像无法抗拒一样。
Irresistible, an oasis. This allure, some might say. So we parked in the parking lot, pulled up, only car there. What a miracle. And just ran out into the supermarket and spent probably like, you know, 15 minutes grabbing our stuff. They came back out, went to the 7-Eleven parking lot, and the car wasn't there. Disappeared. The car was gone. And I was sort of in denial for a second.
无法抗拒，简直就是一片绿洲。有人可能会说是这种诱惑。所以我们把车停在了停车场，开了进去，那是里面唯一的一辆车。简直是个奇迹。然后我们小跑着冲进超市，大概花了，你知道的，15分钟左右的时间拿了我们的东西。他们出来后，回到了7-Eleven的停车场，车却不在了。消失了。车不见了。我有一会儿简直不敢相信。
I was like, well, surely. Like, I just, I'm not that great at remembering where I parked anyway, but it's not a big lot, and it's super brightly lit, and there's no cars there. So she and her friends went into the 7-Eleven to ask if anyone had seen anything. We go to the register, and we're like, I think our car just got stolen. Did you see anyone steal a car? And the guy was like, no, it didn't get stolen, got towed. And this guy is just acting like,
我想，呃，这怎么可能。我是说，我本来就不太擅长记住自己把车停在哪儿，但这停车场不大，而且灯光超级亮，里面一辆车也没有。于是她和朋友们走进7-Eleven，问有没有人看到什么。我们走到收银台前，说：“我觉得我们的车刚刚被偷了。你们看到有人偷车吗？”那个男的说：“没有，没被偷，被拖走了。”这人的态度就好像……
Like he's never heard something more boring in his life. And he was like, yeah, like 20 cars get towed a day. There's a sign out there called the number. Back out in the parking lot, they did find signs warning that unauthorized cars would be towed. One was in Cyrillic. One was covered in graffiti. And another was tucked away in a far corner of the lot. Kelly had the idea to pull up the Google reviews for the 7-Eleven.
就好像他这辈子从来没听过比这更无聊的事一样。然后他说：“对啊，一天大概有20辆车被拖走。外面有标牌，上面有电话号码。”回到停车场后，他们确实找到了警告未经授权的车辆会被拖走的标牌。其中一个是西里尔字母的。一个被涂鸦覆盖了。另一个则藏在停车场的一个角落里。凯莉想到了去查一下这家7-Eleven的谷歌评价。
And they found dozens of people telling pretty much. the same story. Says, I was their customer for many years, gave a great business for all those years, till my car was towed less than six minutes absence. If you read the other one-star review, you'll understand what's going on. This store is running a scam. We bought drinks in the store, and someone called the towing. Never buy anything from this store.
然后他们发现了几十个人的评价，说的几乎都是同一件事。上面写着：“我当了他们多年的顾客，这么多年来为他们贡献了很好的生意，直到我的车在不到六分钟的离开时间内被拖走。”如果你看了另一条一星差评，你就会明白是怎么回事了。这家店在搞诈骗。我们在店里买了饮料，然后有人打电话叫了拖车。千万不要在这家店买任何东西。
Call 3-1-1. Terrible and unethical. Take your car hostage and get $150 from you. I'm Delaney Hall, and this is service request from 99% Invisible. and campside media. We take your burning questions about infrastructure, and we investigate. Kelly eventually got her car back that night, and we will get into that. But the whole experience left her with a question that she could not shake.
打311举报吧。太可怕了，太不道德了。把你的车当人质扣押，然后从你那儿敲诈150美元。我是德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall），这是来自《99%无形》（99% Invisible）和Campside Media的“服务请求”（Service Request）栏目。我们收集你们对基础设施的迫切疑问，并进行调查。凯莉那天晚上最终拿回了她的车，我们稍后会详细讲到。但整个经历给她留下的一个疑问让她挥之不去。
Or really, a whole bunch of questions. How is it that you can just park your car? 15 minutes later, it's gone. I don't know who's in charge of regulating this. I don't know. who empowers these tow truck guys under whose authority are they working? It just feels like this black box of mystery that's affecting clearly a lot of people
或者确切地说，是一连串的问题。怎么就能随随便便把车停好？15分钟后，车就没了。我不知道是谁负责监管这事。我不知道到底是谁赋予了这些拖车司机权力，他们是在谁的授权下工作的？这感觉就像是一个黑箱谜团，显然对很多人造成了影响
if the Google reviews are to be believed. Today, the black box of mystery of towing and impoundment. Who decides when your car gets taken? Who decides where it goes? And when things go wrong, which it turns out, they do a lot. Why is it so hard to fix? When we started trying to find the answer to Kelly's question, I learned the term that describes this kind of practice. It's called predatory towing.
如果谷歌评价可信的话。今天，我们就来揭开拖车和扣车黑箱背后的谜团。谁来决定你的车什么时候被拖走？谁来决定它被拖到哪里？当事情出了岔子——事实证明，这种情况并不少见——为什么修复起来这么难？当我们开始试图寻找凯莉的问题的答案时，我学到了一个用来描述这种做法的术语。这叫掠夺性拖车（predatory towing）。
And it describes towers who actively hunt for cars to pick up and then demand inflated fees when owners try to get them back. Predatory towing happens everywhere. But in some places, it happens a lot. Detroit, Michigan has a well-documented and long-running predatory towing problem. And so that makes it a good case study for us. I mean, it's a big business. It's a multi-million dollar business, and they make a lot of money doing this. Yeah.
它指的是那些疯狂搜寻车辆进行拖曳，然后在车主试图赎回车辆时索取虚高费用的拖车公司。掠夺性拖车无处不在。但在某些地方，这种情况非常多。密歇根州底特律市长期以来一直存在严重的、有据可查的掠夺性拖车问题。所以这为我们提供了一个很好的案例研究。我的意思是，这是一门大生意。这是一门产值达数百万美元的生意，他们靠这个赚了很多钱。是的。
So that's why they do it. This is Tom Berry. He spent 35 years as a police officer in Detroit, and he retired as a lieutenant about a decade ago. Since then, he's worked as a fraud investigator for insurance companies. And he has seen the towing industry from basically every angle. He's been a cop who called tow trucks, and he's been an investigator who's uncovered how corrupt towing companies actually operate. I'm curious, can you help us understand, in an ideal world, how is towing supposed to be a public good? What kind of service do toowers provide when they're working well?
所以这就是他们这么做的原因。这是汤姆·巴里（Tom Berry）。他在底特律当了35年警察，大约十年前以中尉军衔退休。从那以后，他一直担任保险公司的欺诈调查员。他基本上从各个角度见证了拖车行业。他当过需要呼叫拖车的警察，也当过调查员，揭露过腐败的拖车公司究竟是如何运作的。我很好奇，您能帮我们理解一下，在理想世界中，拖车本该是如何发挥公共福利作用的吗？当拖车公司运作良好时，它们提供的是什么样的服务？
If it's working good, which we all like to see, you live on Elm Avenue and you come out one day and you can't get out of your driveway because somebody's parked there. So, of course, you call the police because you've got to go to work. And the police call the tow truck and the tow truck comes out and moves that car out of your way so you can go about your business. That's a good deal. Also, we have accidents. Once they take care of the injured, we need to remove those cars from the road. The tow companies take them to a tow yard. so it can be good.
如果运作良好的话——这是我们都乐见其成的——你住在埃尔姆大道（Elm Avenue），有一天你出门，却发现车开不出车库了，因为有人把车停在那儿。所以，当然了，你得报警，因为你要去上班。然后警察叫来拖车，拖车赶到现场把车移开，这样你就可以去忙你的正事了。这很合理。还有，我们会遇到交通事故。一旦伤者得到妥善处理，我们就需要把这些车从路上移走。拖车公司把它们拉到停车场，所以这可以是件好事。
In many cities, when there's a crash that needs to be cleared or a vehicle that's been abandoned on the street, police will call a private towing company to call it away. That's how it works in Detroit, too. Tom says that when he was a police officer, the department gave him a list of the tow companies that he was allowed to call. These were companies that had a contract with the police
在许多城市，当发生需要清理的撞车事故或有车辆被遗弃在街上时，警察会打电话给私营拖车公司将其拖走。底特律也是这样运作的。汤姆说，当他还是个警察时，警局会给他一份允许呼叫的拖车公司名单。这些公司都是与警方签有合同的公司
to cover a certain area of the city. And most officers would go down the approved list calling companies until one was available to send a tow truck. But years later, as a lieutenant, Tom discovered that not all police officers were doing it that way. They were using a certain toer. They weren't calling the scheduled toers, the toers on the list. They were calling their friend. Some cops were calling tow companies they had a relationship with. And many of those companies were inflating their fees way beyond what a typical tow would cost.
负责城市的一定区域。大多数警员会顺着获批的名单打电话，直到有一家公司有空派拖车过来。但几年后，作为中尉的汤姆发现，并非所有的警员都按规矩办事。他们一直在使用某家特定的拖车公司。他们没有叫排班表上的拖车，也没有叫名单上的拖车。他们在叫他们的朋友。有些警察在呼叫他们有关系的拖车公司。其中许多公司大大抬高了收费，远超正常拖车应有的成本。
Then they'd pay kickbacks to the police officers who sent the business their way. And the corruption kind of swelled. It just keeps surmounting and eventually, you know, it comes crashing down. That's what happened here in Detroit. Eventually, there was a federal investigation into the corruption that Tom is talking about. And some cops went to jail. But that wasn't the end of towing problems in the city. In fact, Tom says some of the most problematic towing doesn't even involve the police.
然后，他们会把回扣给那些把生意介绍给他们的警察。这种腐败就像滚雪球一样不断膨胀。它一直在加剧，最终，你知道的，彻底崩盘了。底特律发生的就是这种情况。最终，联邦对汤姆所说的这种腐败行为展开了调查。一些警察锒铛入狱。但这并不是这座城市拖车问题的终结。事实上，汤姆说，一些问题最大的拖车甚至不涉及警方。
It involves situations like Kellys, where people get towed for parking in a private lot. I'm curious if, kind of zooming out, you can walk me through how a predatory towing operation works. Like, what does a typical day look like? what are the most common schemes that you see? Well, I think that most toors are basically honest. First, I want to give them a little accolade. So what happens? Like your friend there at the 7-Eleven.
它涉及的是像凯莉那样的遭遇，人们因为把车停在私人停车场而被拖走。我很好奇，如果稍微跳出宏观视角，您能向我介绍一下掠夺性拖车是怎么运作的吗？比如，典型的一天是什么样的？您见过的最常见的套路有哪些？嗯，我认为大多数拖车司机基本上都是诚实的。首先，我想对他们大加赞赏一番。那么情况是怎样的呢？就像你那位在7-Eleven的朋友一样。
So it's illegal to park and private property and go to the doctor's office, let's say, or go do your shopping. So if you own a business in your city, you know, McDonald's or Burger King or whatever, and you have private citizens that aren't patronizing your business tying up your lot, and they keep coming in there, and you're losing customers because your lot's full of people going to shop at Macy's, then you're mad. So you, the business owner, can contact, you know, Joe's towing and say, hey, I got a red Chevy out in my lot. Can you come and get it?
所以，把车停在私人物业然后去看医生，比方说，或者去购物，这是违法的。因此，如果你在城里拥有一家企业，你知道的，麦当劳、汉堡王之类的，而有一些不是来你店里消费的普通市民占用了你的车位，他们一直把车停在那儿，导致你因为停车场停满了去梅西百货（Macy's）购物的人而失去顾客，那你就会很生气。所以你，作为企业老板，可以联系，你知道的，乔伊拖车（Joe's towing），说：“嘿，我的停车场里停了一辆红色的雪佛兰。你们能来把它拖走吗？”
It's been here for a half hour. This practice makes sense. A business needs to keep its lot clear for actual customers. And that's what happened to Kelly. She parked at a 7-Eleven, walked to a neighboring restaurant, and then came back to find her car gone. She technically broke the rules, and the tow company had the right to take her car. But there are sketchier tactics that some toowers use to maximize the number of cars they can grab. For instance, spotters.
它已经停了半个小时了。这种做法是合乎情理的。商家需要保持停车场畅通，以便真正有需求的顾客使用。凯莉就是遭遇了这种情况。她把车停在7-Eleven，步行到隔壁餐厅，回来后发现车没了。严格来说她违反了规定，拖车公司有权把车拖走。但有些拖车公司会使用一些更鬼祟的战术，来尽量多拖走一些车。例如，使用“线人”（spotters）。
Spotters are paid citizens that live in that area. I approach them and say, hey, I'm the owner of Joe's towing. And I know that your apartment overlooks the Burger King lot over here. So we meet. It's okay, here's what I want you to do. I want you to watch this lot. And if you see somebody go into that lot and not use the business, you call me. And so I'll be right there.
线人是住在当地并获得报酬的居民。我找到他们然后说：“嘿，我是乔伊拖车的老板。我知道你的公寓正对着这边的汉堡王停车场。所以我们见个面。行了，这是我希望你做的。我希望你帮我盯着这个停车场。如果你看到有人把车停进停车场却不是去消费的，你就给我打电话。这样我就会立刻赶到。”
And if I get the tow job, you get 50 or 100 bucks. So tow truck makes cash. People make 50 bucks, no taxes. Everybody's happy except the person that parked there. Except the person who parked there. So this is interesting. Some tow companies, they basically recruit a neighborhood network of eyes on the ground, of spies. That's a good way to put it.
“如果我接成了这单拖车生意，你就能拿50或100块钱。”所以拖车司机赚了现金。人们赚了50块钱，不用交税。除了把车停在那儿的那个人，每个人都很高兴。除了那个把车停在那儿的人。所以这很有意思。有些拖车公司，他们基本上在社区里招募了一张地面眼线网，也就是间谍网。这么说倒也贴切。
A neighborhood network. Excellent. People who are just keeping an eye on these various parking lots. And when they see someone park there and not use the business, they just give the tow truck driver a call and they get a kickback. Exactly. In some cities, it's illegal for tow companies to use spotters. But not in New York City or in Detroit. One tow company there became so notorious for using spotters, they felt the need to put out this little explainer video on their Facebook page.
一张社区眼线网。太妙了。这些人只是盯着这些不同的停车场。当他们看到有人把车停在那儿却没有消费时，就会给拖车司机打个电话，然后拿回扣。没错。在某些城市，拖车公司使用线人是违法的。但在纽约市或底特律并非如此。当地有一家拖车公司因为使用线人而变得臭名昭著，以至于他们觉得有必要在自己的Facebook主页上发布这段简短的科普视频。
A lot of people think a spotter's illegal, but it's not. There's nothing illegal about it. They're just maintaining parking spaces for the property owner. After the break, we'll talk with a driver who used to work for that notorious Detroit tow company. Well, I guess to start, could you just introduce yourself, like, your name and where you are and what you're doing? My name is Shane Nation. I'm in Detroit, Michigan, and I currently tow, and I've been in the industry for about five years. When I spoke with Shane, he was in his toe. truck between calls on his lunch break. As far as I can tell, there aren't a lot of tow truck
很多人觉得线人是违法的，但其实并不是。这没有任何违法的。他们只是在为业主维护停车位。休息过后，我们将与一位曾为那家臭名昭泽的底特律拖车公司工作的司机聊聊。嗯，我想先请您做个自我介绍，比如您的名字、您在哪里以及您在做什么？我叫沙恩·内森（Shane Nation）。我在密歇根州底特律，我目前从事拖车工作，在这个行业大约有五年了。我和沙恩交谈时，他正坐在午休期间两单任务之间的拖车上。据我所知，并没有多少拖车
drivers who are willing to talk with a journalist about the realities of the job, but Shane is one of them. He started in the industry when he was just 16 years old. Once I started like working in the industry, it's like a bug. It's very hard to go do something where you're not as free. Like go sit in an office or inside all day long. And it honestly, I, It's not boring. There's people that have been towing for 25 years and they'll tell you that they learn new stuff every day because it's just genuinely that type of job. So for people who are not familiar with towing, what is a typical day like in the life of a tow truck driver? You normally sit in the truck, you plan on your phone, do whatever to let time pass. And then you just wait for police calls to come in.
司机愿意跟记者谈论这份工作的现实情况，但沙恩就是其中之一。他16岁时就开始进入这个行业了。一旦我开始在这个行业工作，就像是上瘾了一样。你很难再去从事那种不够自由的工作。比如去办公室坐着，或者一整天都待在室内。老实说，我，这绝不无聊。有些人干了25年拖车，他们会告诉你他们每天都能学到新东西，因为这真的是那种类型的工作。所以对于不熟悉拖车的人来说，拖车司机的真实生活日常是什么样的？你通常坐在卡车里，玩手机打发时间，干点别的来消磨时间。然后你就是等警方电话打进来。
Those could look like impounds, like somebody got arrested. and we would tow their car to impound lot. It could look like a car crash, and we have to be out there cleaning the scene on the highway or something. And it could be as simple as your mom broke down, and she just needs a tow to the mechanic shop and to get her car fixed. Have you towed your mom? Yeah, not my mother.
这些可能包括扣车，比如有人被逮捕了，我们就得把他们的车拖到扣车场。也可能是车祸，我们需要去高速公路或别的地方清理现场。或者也可能很简单，比如你妈妈的车抛锚了，她只需要把车拖到修理厂去修好。你拖过你妈妈的车吗？对，不是我妈。
Luckily, she buys newer vehicles and gets warranties and stuff, but family members, yes. So they're like, oh, I know exactly who to call. Shane. Yeah, unfortunately, that is what seems to be what they do. Shane's first real towing job was with a company in Detroit that had a reputation for predatory towing. Shane doesn't actually have a problem naming this company. He's spoken on TV in Detroit about them.
幸运的是，她买的都是新车，有质保之类的，但是其他亲戚的车，拖过。所以他们就会觉得，哦，我知道该打给谁了。沙恩。是的，不幸的是，他们似乎就是这么做的。沙恩的第一份真正的拖车工作是在底特律的一家公司，这家公司以掠夺性拖车而闻名。沙恩其实并不介意说出这家公司的名字。他在底特律的电视节目中公开谈论过他们。
But we don't want to name them in this episode. We don't want Shane to get in trouble. So since day one there, they would say, hey, look, we're on the news all the time. It is what it is. People don't like their car getting towed. So that's pretty much how I was told there. Like, hey, you're going to see that we're this, this, and that. And just don't believe it because, you know, we're just doing the public of service. And some people don't appreciate that.
但我们不想在这集节目里点名。我们不想让沙恩惹上麻烦。所以从在那里上班的第一天起，他们就会说：“嘿，听着，我们天天上新闻。事情就是这样。人们不喜欢自己的车被拖走。”所以基本上我当时就是这么被灌输的：“嘿，你会发现我们就是这样那样的。但别信那些，因为你知道的，我们只是在为公众服务。有些人对此并不领会。”
At first, Shane thought, maybe that's just how the world works. People just complain to the media a lot. Plus, he liked his job. He liked the trucks and getting greasy and how every day was interesting and new. A lot of the jobs he was doing were private property impounds or PPI's. That's when a tow company has a contract with a property owner, like an apartment complex or a 7-Eleven to tow cars that shouldn't be there. And this company that Shane worked for was aggressive about it.
起初沙恩心想，也许世界就是这样运转的。人们只是经常向媒体抱怨罢了。另外，他很喜欢这份工作。他喜欢卡车，喜欢沾满机油的感觉，喜欢每天都有趣而新鲜。他经手的大多数工作都是私人物业扣车（PPI）。也就是拖车公司与业主（比如公寓大楼或7-Eleven）签订合同，将不该停在那里的汽车拖走。沙恩工作的这家公司在这方面非常激进。
They would work with spotters like the ones Tom told us about. They had people sitting in the parking lot, watching and waiting for someone to park illegally. We had two different spotters. They would sit and tended out cars and just wait for somebody to pull up. We would sit around the corner. We wouldn't be no further than five minutes away. One of the lots Shane worked was across the street from the med center, which is a cluster of major hospitals in downtown Detroit.
他们会与汤姆跟我们提到的那种线人合作。他们会安排人坐在停车场里，盯着并等待有人违章停车。我们有两个不同的线人。他们会坐在那里盯着车，等着有人把车开过来。我们就停在街角附近。离得绝不会超过五分钟。沙恩工作过的一个停车场就在医疗中心（med center）街对面，那是底特律市中心的一个大型医院群。
People would park in the apartment complex lot and then walk across the street to visit someone in the hospital. And Shane's job was to tow their cars the moment they walked away. We'd pull up right away, grab their car, and drive off with it. Now, these people, sometimes they would come out and, you know, they'd be screaming, yelling, I don't have another car, how am I supposed to get to work, how am I supposed to take my kids to school? And when I was 17, I'm not going to lie, I had no remorse for them.
人们会把车停在公寓大楼的停车场里，然后步行穿过街道去医院探望病人。而沙恩的工作就是在他们走开的那一刻把他们的车拖走。我们会立刻把车开过去，勾住他们的车，然后开走。现在这些人，有时他们会冲出来，你知道的，大喊大叫：“我没有别的车了，我怎么去上班，我怎么送孩子去上学？”当我17岁的时候，我不撒谎，我对他们毫无怜悯之心。
I didn't feel bad for them at all. But once I started getting older and having bills to pay and understanding that it's genuinely hard out here in the world to survive, especially on a low income, and then somebody's come in and taking your car when you're just trying to visit, you know, your mom or your dad that's in the hospital. I can understand now that's like just a really crappy thing to do to somebody. Shane says he would sometimes spend whole shifts sitting in his truck near that one parking lot waiting for spotters to call in toes. Because that single lot was sort of a gold mine.
我一点也不替他们感到难过。但随着我年龄渐长，有了账单要付，也开始明白在这个世界上生存真的很艰难，尤其是对低收入人群来说，然后有人进来把你的车拖走了，而你当时只是想去探望一下，你知道的，住在医院里的爸爸或妈妈。我现在能理解，对别人做出这种事真的是一件非常糟糕的行为。沙恩说，他有时会在那个停车场附近的车里度过整个班次，等待线人打电话来通知拖车。因为那个单一的停车场简直就是一座金矿。
It's 100% returns other than the fuel you used. So, I mean, they're making a killing just towing 15 to 20 cars a day off that one lot. And they have all of downtown Detroit. So, I mean, it's a big operation. Given the company's reputation, sometimes the Detroit police would show up to see what was going on. Or they'd respond to complaints from people who were getting their cars towed. But the company was ready for that. Shane says they trained their employees on what to say when the police arrived, which
除了消耗的燃油之外，回报率高达100%。所以，我的意思是，他们光是从那个停车场一天拖走15到20辆车就赚大发了。而且他们拥有整个底特律市中心。所以，我的意思是，这是一笔大生意。鉴于这家公司的名声，底特律警方有时会赶来看看发生了什么。或者他们会回应那些车被拖走的人的投诉。但这家公司对此早有准备。沙恩说，他们会培训员工在警察到达时该说些什么，以及
laws to mention in their arguments for towing a certain car. Shane's interactions with the public weren't any better. It was all so confrontational. They would always beg and plead, and that's understandable, especially if you don't have the money. It was standard. I was constantly, for lack of better word, I was constantly the a-hole in every predicament I've ever, like every interaction I had, I was the aggressor. and I just say it wasn't a good feeling.
在争辩拖走某辆车时应该提及哪些法律。沙恩与公众的互动也好不到哪里去。一切都充满了对抗性。他们总是苦苦哀求，这也可以理解，尤其是当你没钱的时候。这是常态。我一直在，用一个不太恰当的词来说，我在每一种困境中、在我所有的每一次互动中，我都是那个混蛋，我总是那个咄咄逼人的攻击者。我只能说这感觉真不好。
If you think about it, it is kind of wild that these non-law enforcement private companies are allowed to just take people's unattended vehicles. Shane says that bad practices are common in the world of private property impounds because there are basically no checks in the system. Definitely. It's the least regulated. You're not pulling up on a police scene with police there, and you're not pulling up on a broken down vehicle with the car, car's owner there. You're pulling up on an unintended vehicle that you have full access to. And,
如果你仔细想想，这些非执法机构的私营公司竟然可以随便把别人无人看管的车辆拖走，这确实挺疯狂的。沙恩说，在私人物业扣车领域，不良作风很常见，因为这个系统基本上没有任何制约。确实如此。这是监管最松懈的。你不是去面对有警察在场的执法现场，也不是去面对有车主在场的抛锚车辆。你面对的是一辆你拥有完全接触权的无人看管的车辆。而且，
I mean, you just hook up this car and you call the police nearby and you go, hey, I'm towing this car because it's parked incorrectly on this lot. There's no verification of this whatsoever. You just, you call the police and you tell them you're doing it and they put the system, they put the car in lean so it can't be reported stolen. That's all it is to PPI's and there's just no verification in the system so everybody exploits it. So you're doing this at this apartment complex lot. You've gotten a little older. You're like, this doesn't feel good because you understand kind of the implications of having your car towed. It's expensive. It's like a huge headache. So what happened from there? So it was never that like I wanted to continue doing it. It was kind of the fact that I had bills to pay in my own
我的意思是，你只需要把这辆车勾住，给附近的警察局打个电话，然后说：“嘿，我正在拖走这辆车，因为它在这个停车场违章停放。”这根本没有任何核实过程。你只需要，你给警察打电话告诉他们你正在这么做，他们就会把车辆登记在留置权（lien）系统中，这样它就不会被当作失窃车辆报案。私人物业扣车就是这么回事，系统中没有任何核实机制，所以每个人都在利用这个漏洞。所以你在这个公寓大楼的停车场干这事。你年纪稍长了一点。你觉得：这感觉真不好，因为你开始理解车被拖走的后果。这很贵。这简直是一场巨大的噩梦。那么接下来发生了什么？
family to feed is why I stayed there for so much longer after that time period. Right. But yeah, like, I hated it every day after that. Like, it made me lose my love for towing, and I genuinely just wanted out in any way, shape, or form by the end of it. Shane was having a full-blown crisis of conscience. He dreaded going to work and spending all day towing people who he believed didn't really deserve it.
所以，并不是说我一直想继续干下去。我之所以在那之后还待了那么久，很大程度上是因为我有账单要付，有自己的家庭要养。对吧。但是，是的，从那以后我每天都讨厌这份工作。这让我失去了对拖车工作的热爱，到了最后，我只想以任何可能的、形形色色方式摆脱它。沙恩经历了一场彻头彻尾的良心危机。他害怕上班，害怕整天去拖那些他认为罪不至此的人的车。
Eventually, he left the predatory tow company. He thought he might go back to working in fast food. But instead, he started with a different company where he was doing different kinds of toes. I just didn't want to do PPI. That was my biggest thing, was private property impounds feel like they're just not necessary. Like, at least in the way they did it. Like, it was just unnecessary. And I just did them so much 24-7 that I just didn't want to do them ever again.
最终，他离开了那家掠夺性拖车公司。他曾想过或许可以回去做快餐业。但相反，他去了一家不同的公司，在那里他做的是不同类型的拖车。我只是不想再干私人物业扣车了。这是我最大的想法，私人物业扣车让人感觉完全没有必要。至少以他们那种方式来说是这样。这就纯粹是多此一举。我之前24小时连轴转地干得太多了，以至于我再也不想碰这行了。
And that was my main thing. Where I'm at now, all I do is services. Like, I'm not towing anybody's car because I want to. You know, it's simply they call or the police call, and I'm going there to either clean up the wreck or I'm going there to get those people home. Especially where I'm at now, it's never the case that I'm going there for any other reason other than to service them. These conversations with Tom and Shane helped me understand so much better. what might have happened with Kelly's car. She was involved in a private property impound situation.
这就是我的主要诉求。我现在呆的地方，我做的全都是救援服务。比如，我不会因为我想赚钱去拖任何人的车。你知道的，纯粹是他们打电话或者警察打电话，我去那里要么是清理事故现场，要么是去送那些人回家。尤其是我现在呆的地方，我去的唯一原因就是为了提供服务，绝无其他目的。与汤姆和沙恩的这些对话，让我更好地理解了
She parked at that 7-Eleven illegally. There may have been a spotter that saw her do it, and the company probably had a relationship with a toer who was contacted as soon as she walked away. So after standing in the parking lot, trying to figure out what to do, she and her friends decided to call the tow company. So we called the number,
凯莉的车当时可能遭遇了什么。她卷入了一起私人物业扣车事件。她把车违法停在了那家7-Eleven。可能有个线人看到了她这么做，而该公司很可能与某个拖车司机有合作，在她刚走开时就联系了对方。所以在停车场里站着、试图想办法解决问题时，她和朋友们决定给拖车公司打电话。所以我们打了那个电话，
and we actually had to call like multiple times to get the information we needed because like we'd call and then they would hang up or we'd call and sort of not get the right information. At one point, Kelly asked the tow company to confirm that they had her car by reading back the license plate number. And they're like, we can't give you the license plate. And at one point they were like, yeah, we have your car, but come back tomorrow. It was all extremely confusing, but eventually Kelly took a cab home to let her dog out for a walk, and her friends
而且我们实际上不得不打好几次电话才能拿到我们需要的信息，因为有时打过去他们会直接挂断，或者打过去却得不到正确的信息。有一次，凯莉要求拖车公司通过念出车牌号来确认他们确实扣了她的车。而他们却说：“我们不能把车牌号告诉你。”还有一次他们说：“对，我们有你的车，但明天再来吧。”整个过程极其混乱，但最终凯莉坐出租车回家放狗出去遛弯，她的朋友们
decided to go get the car themselves. The impound lot was about a mile from the 7-Eleven, and they had to walk there. They eventually found the place, and through the holes in the front gate, they could see Kelly's car. They got there and there was a building that
决定自己去把车取回来。扣车场离7-Eleven大约有一英里远，他们不得不步行前往。他们最终找到了那个地方，透过正门的洞，他们能看到凯莉的车。他们走到那里，发现有一栋建筑
was brightly lit up inside, indicating that perhaps the office was not actually closed, but they were brought in to this building and the guy was like it's going to be $350 to get your car back because the office is closed right now. Wow. That's a lot of money. Yeah, especially. I'm pretty sure the sign said 125. Like the sign had a pay scale on there and he was immediately like that's going to be 350. So there's sort of this, there's this negotiation going on. It's like. Oh yeah. Yeah, totally. There's
里面灯火通明，这表明办公室可能并没有真正关门，但他们被带进了这座建筑，然后那个人说：“取回你的车需要350美元，因为现在办公室已经关门了。”哇。这可是一大笔钱。对啊，尤其如此。我很确定标牌上写的是125。标牌上有一个收费阶梯，而他立刻开口就要350。所以这就变成了一种，这中间有一种协商。就像是。哦，对。是的，完全是。这
totally a negotiation. And it included like at first they said, oh, because I'm not physically there, that's an extra fee. And then they said, oh, the business is closed. It's after hours. So that's another fee. But there wasn't actually a fee structure. It was just like a negotiation, like a bartering. They were just making it up. Yeah. They kidnapped my car and then like ransomed it for an uncertain amount of based on how much cash my friends had on hand. Like, it's crazy they can do that. But according to Tom, the retired cop, tow companies do this all the time. They pretend they're closed so that people have to come back the next day, and that allows
完全是一场讨价还价。其中包括，他们一开始说：“哦，因为我本人没在那儿，所以要收额外费用。”然后他们又说：“哦，现在营业结束了。已经过营业时间了。”所以这是另一笔费用。但实际上根本没有什么收费标准。这就纯粹是一场协商，就像讨价还价一样。他们完全是信口开黄。对啊。他们绑架了我的车，然后像勒索赎金一样，根据我朋友手头有多少现金来索要不确定的金额。这太荒谬了，他们竟然能这么干。但在退役警察汤姆看来，拖车公司一直都在这么做。他们假装自己已经下班，好让人们第二天不得不再次前往，这使得
them to inflate the storage fees they charge. They demand to see registration and insurance, which is often in the car that's been impounded, and so people have to run around gathering new documents. It might take them a day, it might take them two days to go get that information and bring it back to satisfy the tow company. Meanwhile, another 50 bucks a day, another 50 bucks a day for keeping your car. Often, these businesses don't disclose their fee structures. And even when they do, the fees can be manipulated. So, well, it came in on the second at 11 o'clock at night, and here it is the third, and it's 1 o'clock in the morning.
他们能够大幅抬高收取的仓储费。他们要求查看车辆登记证和保险，而这些通常都在被扣的车里面，所以人们不得不四处奔走收集新文件。这可能需要花上一天甚至两天的时间去获取这些信息并带回来交差，以满足拖车公司的要求。与此同时，每天还要多掏50块钱，每天因为扣留你的车而多收50块钱。通常，这些企业不会公开他们的收费结构。即便他们公开了，费用也可以被人为操纵。比如，“嗯，车是2号晚上11点进来的，现在已经是3号了，凌晨1点。”
Well, that's two days' stories. $110. Well, wait a minute. My car's only been here for two hours. Yeah, but that's the way it is. Because it's technically touched two days, even if it was just a few hours in the middle of the night. I see. Exactly. Kelly's friends were lucky, if you can call it that, because they showed up that same night. They eventually paid $200 to get the car back. It's really, really sketchy. Like, none of this feels legal. you can just take someone's car, ransom it, figure out an amount of money between you, and then they said no receipt. So they just had to pay their $200.
“好吧，这算两天的费用。110美元。”“等等，我的车才停了两个小时啊。”“对，但规矩就是这样。”因为在技术上它跨越了两天，哪怕它只是在半夜停了短短几个小时。我明白了。完全正确。凯莉的朋友们很走运——如果这也能算走运的话——因为他们当天晚上就赶到了。他们最终支付了200美元才把车赎回来。这真的非常非常离谱。这感觉完全不合法。你可以随随便便把别人的车开走，勒索赎金，在你们之间敲定一个金额，然后他们说没有收据。所以他们只能付那200美元。
How else you're going to get your car back? Like, these five guys have it. What else are you going to do? It almost seems like the towers don't want you to get your car back. Or at the very least, they might not mind if you don't retrieve your car. Well, what some of these tow companies do, they know good cars and bad cars. You know what I mean by that? Like, hey, that's an older car, but he's got good treads on it, good struts.
不然你还能怎么把车拿回来？这五个大汉手里握着车呢。你还能怎么办？这简直让人觉得拖车公司根本不想让你把车拿回去。或者至少，如果你不把车赎回去，他们也无所谓。嗯，其中一些拖车公司会挑选好车和破车。你懂我这话的意思吗？比如：“嘿，那是一辆老旧的车，但轮胎花纹很好，减震器也很棒。”
You know, it looks pretty okay. I could probably get some money for that. So they kind of pull that to the side of the auction that they have every 30 days. Cars are valuable. So this is another way they're making money. Exactly. They hold a person's car until the fees are so high the person can't afford to get it out.
“你知道的，看起来还挺不错的。我或许能从那辆车上搞点钱。”所以他们会把那辆车拉到一旁，准备放进他们每30天举办一次的拍卖会里。汽车是有价值的。所以这也是他们赚钱的途径之一。没错。他们扣押着车主的车，直到费用高得车主根本无力赎回。
Get it out. Yeah. And then they sell that car at all. auction, scrap it for parts, make money on the car itself. That's why it's a multi-million dollar business towing us. And people don't realize that. For that reason, Tom says bad toers might target cars that look a little bit junky or old, like Kelly's 2011 Mazda, cars that look like they might be underinsured,
无力赎回。是的。然后他们把那辆车拿去拍卖，或者拆解当废铁卖零件，从中牟利。这就是为什么拖车是一门产值达数百万美元的生意。人们并没有意识到这一点。出于这个原因，汤姆说不良拖车公司可能会把目标对准那些看起来有点破旧或老化的汽车，比如凯莉那辆2011年的马自达，那些看起来可能投保不足的汽车，
or their owners might not have hundreds of dollars on hand to get them back. Because they're easy targets. And generally, those owners of those cars, don't squeak. They don't make complaints. I don't know if that's their reasoning, but it sounds reasonable to me. Go after the low-hanging fruit versus the high-hanging fruit. Toers can get away with this in part because there's very little oversight. The towing industry is regulated by a patchwork of laws across the country.
或者车主手头没有几百美元现金来赎回的车。因为它们是容易下手的软柿子。而且一般来说，那些车的车主不会大声叫屈。他们不会去投诉。我不知道这是否是他们的理由，但听起来确实有道理。专挑软柿子捏，而不是去摘高处的果子。拖车公司之所以能屡屡得手，部分原因在于缺乏监管。整个拖车行业受制于全国各地五花八门的法律。
They vary state-by-state. According to research done by a consumer watchdog group, only about half of states set a cap on towing or embeds. more than 30 states don't require rates to be displayed or disclosed. 13 states don't even require the towing company to notify you that your car has been towed. And in 34 states, kickbacks are legal, all of which creates a massive gray area. Some of what they do just sounds like aggressive business practices. You know, like towing companies working hard, working proactively.
各州的规定各不相同。根据消费者监督机构的研究，只有大约一半的州对拖车费或扣车费设定了上限。30多个州不要求公布或公开收费标准。13个州甚至不要求拖车公司在你的车被拖走时通知你。在34个州，给回扣是合法的，所有这些都造成了一个巨大的灰色地带。他们的一些行为听起来就像是激进的商业行为。你知道的，比如拖车公司为了努力工作、积极主动地
to tow illegally parked cars and to make money. And I guess I'm wondering, when do you think it crosses the line from, you know, going hard for business to something more like fraud? You know, I don't know where the line is, but there's certainly a wavy line there that nobody knows about it. It's interesting what you're saying, because it strikes me as part of the problem, which is that you hear about these tactics that bad towers use and they just seem unfair. And yet, it's not totally clear they're breaking some law. You're absolutely right. There's a big gray area
拖走违章停车的车辆并以此赚钱。我想知道的是，在您看来，它究竟是在什么时候从“努力开展业务”越界变成了类似于欺诈的行为？你知道的，我不知道这条线在哪里，但那里确实存在一条谁也说不清的模糊界限。你说的很有意思，因为这让我觉得这就是问题的一部分，那就是你听说过这些不良拖车公司使用的套路，它们看起来很不公平。然而，又不能完全确定他们是在违法。你说的绝对没错。那里存在一个巨大的灰色地带
there that huge. So the only way to stop it is get a law, make a law or an ordinance in the city you can make it and prosecute them. And don't take your foot off the gas. And, And unfortunately, many cities don't fight it till it's so out of control that now they can't get it all back in the box. You know, the box has been open and that crap's flying all around. How are you going to get that box closed again? You know, it's difficult. And that's what happens when you let little things like the little toe. Hey, you charged your four days stone, you only had it one.
而且面积巨大。所以制止它的唯一方法就是立法，在城市里制定法律或条例并起诉他们。并且绝不能有丝毫松懈。而且，不幸的是，许多城市直到事情失控到无法收拾的地步才开始与之抗争。你知道的，潘多拉魔盒已经打开了，那些烂事满天飞。你又怎么能把这个盒子重新关上呢？你知道的，这很难。而这就是当你纵容那些小事情时的后果，比如小小的拖车费——“嘿，你按四天收停车费，可车在你那儿才呆了一天。”
When you do that, if you don't stop it, it's just going to be six days, seven days, because that's what happens. That's just human nature. just going to keep growing. So the only way to stop it, in my opinion, is sort of nip it in the bud, you know, stop it when it's small so we can control it. Tom's advice is to pass regulations and then crack down. But some cities have tried a different approach. They've just cut private towers out entirely, and they've set up their own public towing operations. But getting that going can be a heavy lift. It requires a city to acquire land for the impoundment lot and trucks to do the towing and people to staff the operation.
当你这么做时，如果你不加以阻止，它就会变成六天、七天，因为事情就是这样的。这就是人性。它只会不断膨胀。所以在我的看法里，制止它的唯一方法就是在萌芽状态解决它，你知道的，在它规模还小的时候就把它掐断，这样我们才能控制得住。汤姆的建议是出台法规然后进行打击。但有些城市尝试了不同的方法。他们彻底切断了私营拖车公司的业务，建立了自己的公共拖车运营体系。但要做到这一点可绝非易事。它需要城市获得用于建设扣车场的土地、用于拖车的卡车以及配备运营的人员。
How common is it for a city to have their own trucks, their own lot? I don't think it's common. I think it's a rarity. And why isn't it more common? It's a lot. Who's going to oversee it? You're going to have policemen oversee it. There's so many cost considerations, I think, for that. That they just don't want to do it. They want somebody else to do it, which I would I think that's what happens with the cities, is they don't want to deal with it. What's one piece of advice you have for someone whose car has just been towed?
一个城市拥有自己的卡车和停车场，这种情况普遍吗？我觉得不普遍。我认为这很罕见。那为什么不更普遍一点呢？这牵涉太多了。谁来监督？难道要派警察去监督吗？我认为这里面有很多成本方面的考量。以至于他们根本不想这么做。他们希望别人来干这活儿，我想城市大概就是这种心态，他们就是不想处理这摊事。对于车刚被拖走的人，您有什么建议吗？
Of course, it's a situation. If it was legitimate, you had an accident, and the police come out in a normal city, and they're going to tow it to their yard, that's the way it should go. If you got insurance on your car, let it run its course. Make your claim, call your company, make an insurance claim, But be aware of, especially in parking private property toes. It's extremely lucrative. When you pull into a lot, if you see a sign, you know, this area controlled by Tom's towing,
当然，这要看情况。如果是合法的，你出了事故，正常城市的警察赶到现场，然后把车拖到他们的停车场，事情本该如此。如果你给车买了保险，那就按流程走。提出索赔，给你的公司打电话，进行保险索赔，但是要保持警惕，尤其是在私人物业拖车方面。这极其暴利。当你把车开进停车场时，如果你看到一个牌子，你知道的，“此区域由汤姆拖车监控”，
you know, violators will be towed. Pay attention to those signs because a lot of those places, they got somebody watching. And they're going to tow you. Be careful with your park. What I hear you saying when I say, you know, what's your piece of advice? it's basically don't get towed. Like, do not get yourself caught up in this situation. If you come out and they got the car on the hook, okay, pay the drop fee.
“违者拖走”。请注意这些标志，因为很多地方都有人在盯着。而且他们真的会把你的车拖走。停车时要小心。我听你的意思，当我问“你有什么建议”时，基本上就是“别被拖走”。也就是，千万别让自己卷入这种境地。如果你出来时他们已经把车勾上了，好吧，把放车费（drop fee）付了吧。
Pay it. Just pay it right down. You're saving yourself time, aggravation, trouble, problems, just pay it. Try to negotiate it down. Say, you know what? And this is what I tell people. Let's say it's 400. Say, oh, my God.
付了。立刻付清。这样能帮你省下时间、烦恼、麻烦和问题，付了吧。尽量把价格往下谈。说：“你知道吗？”这也是我常跟别人说的。假设费用是400美元。你可以说：“天呐。”
Would you take $250? barter, barter, barter. But get your car back. Yeah, get your car back. Don't leave it. Don't wait. Don't wait. We started with the question.
“你肯收250美元吗？”讨价还价，讨价还价，讨价还价。但一定要把车赎回来。对，把车拿回来。别留在那里。别等。别拖延。我们开始时提出了一个问题。
How is it that you can just park your car at a 7-Eleven, 15 minutes later it's gone, and you have to negotiate a ransom with some guy in a dark parking lot, and that is an actual business. And we have a pretty good answer. The reality is that towing regulation varies state by state. But in many places, towing companies have contracts with private businesses to monitor and tow illegally parked cars in their lots.
怎么就能随随便便把车停在7-Eleven，15分钟后车就没了，你还得跟黑停车场里的某个家伙谈判勒索赎金，而这居然是一门真正的生意。我们得到了一个相当不错的答案。现实情况是，各州的拖车法规各不相同。但在许多地方，拖车公司与私营企业签有合同，负责监控并拖走其停车场内违章停放的车辆。
Some toowers use spotters. Those are people who keep an eye on parking lots and call the tow company as soon as they see someone park there illegally. Some tow companies don't post their fees and then bargain with people once they show up to try and reclaim their car. And in many states, there are few regulations governing how tow companies operate. With that, Kelly, consider your service request, resolved. Today on the show, you heard Kelly Prime, an editor with 99% invisible.
一些拖车公司会使用线人。这些人盯着停车场，一旦看到有人违章停车就立刻给拖车公司打电话。一些拖车公司不公示收费标准，等人们赶来试图赎回车辆时再跟他们讨价还价。而且在许多州，几乎没有针对拖车公司运营方式的监管法规。好了，凯莉，你的服务请求算是解决了。在今天的节目中，你听到了凯莉·普莱姆的声音，她是《99%无形》的一位编辑。
You also heard Tom Berry, a retired police officer who's now an investigator for the insurance industry. And Shane Nation, a tow truck driver in Detroit. What infrastructure mystery keeps you up at night? Is there something in your life that you use every day but you don't actually understand how it works? Submit your service request by recording a voice memo with your question and emailing it to service request at 99PI.org. And remember, if your car gets towed, try to negotiate the price down. Or better yet, don't get towed in the first place.
你还听到了汤姆·巴里的声音，他是一名退休警察，现在是保险行业的调查员。以及底特律的拖车司机沙恩·内森。究竟是什么基础设施谜团让你夜不能寐？生活中是不是有什么东西你每天都在用，但实际上并不理解它是如何运作的？提交你的服务请求：录制一段包含你疑问的语音备忘录，并将其发送至servicerequest@99PI.org。记住，如果你的车被拖走了，尽量把价格往下谈。或者更好的是，一开始就别让车被拖走。
I'm Delaney Hall. Infrastructure is everywhere, and we're here to help you decode it. Service request is a production of 99% Invisible and Campside Media. The show is produced and fact-checked by Julia Case Levine and edited by Shoshi Shmulevitz. Mix by Iwan Li Trimuan. Theme song and music by Swan Reall. Additional editing by Emmett Fitzgerald and Vivian Lay. Show art by Aaron Nestor.
我是德兰尼·霍尔。基础设施无处不在，我们在此带您解读。\u201c服务请求\u201d是 99% Invisible 和 Campside Media 联合制作的节目。本节目由朱莉娅·凯斯·莱文（Julia Case Levine）制作并核实事实，肖希·什穆列维茨（Shoshi Shmulevitz）剪辑。混音由伊万·李·特里穆安（Iwan Li Trimuan）完成。主题曲及音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Reall）创作。埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）参与了额外剪辑。节目封面由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）设计。
Roman Mars is our boss at 99PI. is our executive producer. Matt Cher is the executive producer at Campside. We are a part of the SiriusXM podcast family. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是我们在 99PI 的老板。是我们的执行制片人。马特·切尔（Matt Cher）是 Campside 的执行制片人。我们是 SiriusXM 播客大家庭的一部分。您可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上可以找到相关链接以及 99PI 的所有往期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。